hi everyone welcome to our daily
homeroom livestream this is a way that
we're trying to keep everyone in touch
during school closures it's a place for
us to answer any questions you have
talked about how we can just navigate
this crisis together we have a really
exciting guest today Ray Dalio I'll give
them a more formal introduction in a
little bit but before we get into the
meat of that conversation with Ray I'll
just remind everyone Khan Academy is a
not-for-profit organization we exist
because of philanthropic donations from
folks like yourself and I want to give a
special shout out to several
corporations who stepped up in the last
few weeks to make sure you know Khan
Academy is running at a deficit even
before this crisis and our deficit has
grown through the crisis and special
shout-out to Bank of America to Novartis
to fastly to Google org and AT&T for
helping us respond to this crisis but we
still need more support so if you're in
a position to do so please think about
making a donation to Khan Academy but
with that I'd like to introduce our
guest that I'm super excited about Ray
Dalio is what has been something a hero
of mine back in from my previous career
when I used to be a hedge fund analyst
for those of you who don't know ray
ray is a founder of Bridgewater
associates which is the largest hedge
fund in the world and so I think we're
gonna have a really interesting
conversation about finance the economy
that we're in and a lot of the work that
Ray and his wife Barbara are doing
around philanthropy to try to help
address issues around education and and
other things and so if anyone has
questions feel free to come on Facebook
and YouTube on the message boards we
have team members looking at questions
ask questions about the economy ask
questions about hedge funds ask
questions about education rate raise
going to and and and and myself well
we'll hopefully be able to address a lot
of them so ray thank you so much for
joining
so is great to be with you and Ray may
be a good place to start and you know
full disclosure ray and Barbara have
been longtime supporters of Khan Academy
and philanthropy in a lot of different
dimensions so thank you for that but you
know when you say largest hedge fund in
the world I think a lot of people hurt
have heard of the word hedge fund but
then they say what is a hedge fund so
what do you do how is that different
than
types of investment vehicles well you
know most investment vehicles go up or
down with the markets like the stock
market goes up they make money stock
market goes down they lose money some go
into bonds and so on a hedge fund
doesn't have a bias so you can make
money if it goes down you can make money
if it goes up it just depends on whether
you can make money so we can invest in
all the markets in the world and we can
do it in a way where if they went down
or we went up you have opportunities to
make money the only thing that limits us
is our own abilities yeah you know with
that example the exhibition I always
used to give to folks when I was an
analyst of the hedge fund is its it
hedge funds have more flexibility to to
make more different types of investments
now there's a huge variety of them of
different strategies but to your point
they don't necessarily just track the
market type of thing yes and ours is
it's an extension of my own personal
passion which is to understand how the
world works economically every country
so we're in just about every country
just about every market and so we have
to see the world and try to piece it all
together so that's my passion and maybe
that's a good place to start at that
very high level because even before the
kovat crisis started this was many
months ago
you have been a very vocal speaker and
writer about a wealth inequality and
when you speak people are listening
because obviously you understand the
economy you manage a lot of assets
what's your view on this issue of wealth
inequality well I think it comes down to
values you know I was born in 1949 in
1945 we began a new world order what I
mean is we created a new monetary system
the United States won the war and we
began an American era and at that time
there was clear it was clear what an
American dream was and so I grew up
and a household where I've got two
parents my dad was a jazz musician all
the middle-class family and I was but
the notion of equal opportunity through
good education I went to public school
and the that notion of what was fair
equal opportunity on a broad base basis
was what the American dream was I I'm
not sure that everybody would know what
the American Dream is or make it for
statement that way but in any case it's
become lost or it certainly doesn't
exist in when we take education for
example I looked at the conditions of
the different top quintile top 20% next
20% I found that the top 40 percent of
the population spends on average five
times as much money on their kids
education as the bottom 60% and so
through intimate contact and so on we
can see that there is not just the
wealth gap there's an opportunity gap
and a productivity gap that's a problem
and it's a problem in terms of its
outcomes that wealth difference but it's
also a structural problem in that all
the people can't be have an equal shot
at being productive and when you see
some of the conditions kids who are
living in neighborhoods of poverty and
go to school to get food because they
don't have enough at home and and the
services something's wrong so I wrote a
piece that's on LinkedIn which is why
and how capitalism needs to be reformed
because I believe that it first of all
if you don't have a situation where
people have opportunity you're not only
tapping failing to tap all the potential
that exists which is on economic but
you're also threatening the existence of
the system and I think that's coming to
home very clearly with this
downturn in the economy and virus and to
be clear you know I'm looking at some of
your blog you wrote why and how
capitalism needs to be reformed you know
the data is very clear that's not under
debate that inequality has gotten worse
over the last several decades you have
charts like you know you look at per
capita GDP and for the bottom 60% of
earners it's growing much slower than
per capita GDP and for the top 40
percent it's growing much faster and
that leads to what you just talked about
people at the upper quartiles are able
to spend more on their children's
education so that kind of becomes a
self-perpetuating thing what what why do
you think this has been the case what
are the structural elements that have
caused this and in your opinion what
needs to change yeah a great question
because I don't think it's anybody's
evilness always not many peoples of
evilness it is structural so for example
of the profit-making system is a system
in which it's a very effective resource
allocation because if what you are
putting out uses is worth more than what
it cost you to make it on you grow and
you get capital that's invested in it
and it grows that way but it's not
effective in a number of ways on it
profit-making system for example
business is not effective in creating
educational resource as well and so that
large gap it becomes a self-reinforcing
gap particularly in this age when
there's a change in the economic rewards
for production workers the average
worker that there's a whole hollowing
out there and so profit margins
increased and then as you point out it
becomes self-perpetuating because those
who earn more money take care of their
children differently that so creates an
opportunity gap they spend money on
different things and so resources of the
country go into those things and then
naturally in a desire to spend produce
most cost-effectively they go
internationally and
and find the Kapost cost-effective ways
of operating which has narrowed the
wealth gap between countries but widened
it within countries and then also we
have a monetary policy with the Federal
Reserve that buys financial assets in
other words the central bank the way it
has been operating when you have zero
interest rates is to print money and
then buy financial assets which helps
those who own financial assets more than
those who don't
so the profit-making system and the
capitalist system in which you can
invest in profitable enterprises
is is is good at generally speaking as a
resource allocation but far from perfect
so we just have to see those outcomes
and you would say do we are we producing
a broad-based opportunity and so it
can't do everything so think about let's
say a school system a budget for a
school system its budget faced in other
words they don't have capital but yet
think about the economic impact simply
of educating children well so the point
is that it's by and large a pretty good
system but it's not delivering the
results that I think we want and so my
concern is that if it's not engineered
correctly too cheap to achieve that it
can become less productive so from an
engineering point of view you have to in
engineer it to increase the size of the
pie which means increased people's
productivity because you only get to
consume what is produced so to raise
living standards you have to increase
productivity and at the same time so you
have to increase the size of the pie you
also have to divide the pie well and
it's going to require a better
engineering system and that is going to
have to be done I think in a bipartisan
way I'm really worried about the battle
between the side causing more problems
because history has shown
but this is a period very much like the
1930s and when you have wealth problems
and wealth gaps in difficult times there
tends to be a fight over how to divide
the pie and so I'm hearing just a
paraphrase what you said several levers
that might have maybe gotten us here and
once again it's not anyone's negative
intent it's just the reality technology
has made knowledge work maybe more
productive and has maybe commoditized
some labor type of work and then you add
globalization there that also puts wage
pressure at least domestically
especially in rich countries if some of
that work you can go other places and
then that can be self-perpetuating the
people who have more are able to invest
more in their children and have have
more opportunities what do you think is
this alert in the Federal Reserve and
like my phanie last debts helps people
who have financial assets which they
needed to do this the policies that
we're now seeing now are more targeted
than they were before and that goes to a
question from Twitter
ken asks I want to understand where the
Fred the Fed printed money or government
still stimulus is going to and you just
explain you the Fed printed money is
going to the it's going to go by
financial assets traditionally Treasury
bonds but other time other things when
it gets more aggressive I won't
understand how the new money is flowing
into the system so I guess you could go
over that a little bit but what do you
think are going to be the main
implications of this kind of aggressive
action of where the money is flowing in
either from fiscal or monetary policy
well thank you for that question isn't
it Fred
Thank You Fred ken um yeah thank you Ken
yeah what we had before was that what I
described that the Federal Reserve would
buy bonds and then it would go in the
financial system because the seller of
bonds would get the cash and they were
an investor so they would buy more
investments and it wouldn't trickle down
in the same way what we have now is
exactly what happened in the Great
Depression April 9 of this year was
exactly like March 5th
19:33 and in March 5th 1933 the newly
elected President Roosevelt got on a
fireside chat and explained that they
were going to produce a lot more money
by central banks and they were going to
the value of the dollar and they were
going to enter into a lot of programs so
these programs but I should explain the
central government has the right to tax
and spend and determine how they do that
but it doesn't have the right to print
money the Federal Reserve the central
bank has the right to print money but
they don't have the right to determine
how it's spent
and so in coming together these Federal
Reserve and the government central
government target programs and so
they're now targeted at individuals
which so the government central
government is targeting individuals
companies and so on in a number of ways
and the Federal Reserve is buying the
debt so that they do that so they're
producing money new money and credit and
that'll have implications for the value
of money and credit but it's much more
targeted so we now see those programs
targeting of course there's they're
they're complex but they really are
targeted more for individuals and small
businesses although there are big
businesses targeted as well so that's
the nature of the dynamic that money and
credit like in the Great Depression will
reverse deflation I could explain it I
don't I worried that sometimes they
answer the questions too long but there
are economic holes you know you can
think about it as a hole in income and a
hole in balance sheets and if you don't
fill those holes then there will be less
spending and they'll be asset sales so
that produces a deflationary depression
so the action
that are now being taken are meant to
fill those holes for Americans others
outside the country will not have that
benefit but there emptor gated to fill
those holes and it won't be inflationary
because it's negating deflationary but
we're entering a whole new period of
time which I hope we can talk about yeah
and and let's talk about that a little
bit from YouTube Rocha and Santi asks so
does confirmed that you can't is it
confirmed the economy will go into
recession after this coronavirus I'm
more worried about the recession than
the virus because I'm afraid of jobs
being lost what's your view there of
what's likely to happen as we go out of
the the coronavirus or maybe just will
slightly happen over the next 18 months
where it still might be out there I
think of the virus I like being a
tsunami that's come and then when it
goes away and we don't let's say was to
go away forever there's still terrible
damage and the terrible damage is to
incomes and to balance sheets you know
every individual every company and every
government has a certain amount of
revenue and a certain amount of expenses
and then they have a savings a certain
amount of balance sheet those have been
severely damaged so the loss of income
and bringing it down relative to
expenses is necessitating cutbacks and
then the balance sheet means great
losses think about companies like Disney
by way of example you think where was
Disney well Disney will have that yet
many many companies many individuals
many small businesses that financial
damage is is is it isn't is a great
great damage this will be the worst
economic downturn since the Great
Depression
it's the unemployment rate will approach
20% the downturn in the economy will be
the largest since the Great Depression
and the financial consequences
financial wreckage of this will be of
that magnitude the good thing is that
the government is acting quickly to to
fill those holes in however it's not
being felt by everybody in the same way
you know we think of the economy there's
you know the rich and the poor and you
know and it's going up and down and I
think we think that when the it returns
it's just going to come back to what it
was there's going to be a restructuring
of that there's going to be a
restructure - people will think policies
makers will think who's going to pay
what what bills and what should it be
going forward so there'll be a
reallocation of resources tax rates are
going to change and also on thoughts of
spending - I think to establish more of
an acceptable bottom because it's so
disproportionately felt by those who
don't have savings or don't have
conditions we can see just even groups
that are have social content the poor
lived closer together and so in many
many different ways that will be
rethought amount and what do you think
is the limit of government action as you
mentioned the government can borrow
money in the form of Treasuries to spend
on programs the interest rate can stay
down if the Fed keeps buying those
Treasuries with printed money and just
in the last few weeks they've issued you
know two trillion dollars of programs
how many trillions can the government
spend to try to do this before you start
seeing things like inflation pick up ah
you have a situation where we're testing
the limits of our monetary monetary
policy the capacity to print money this
is very much like the
for years so in the Great Depression
there was this kind of spending and
these kinds of deficits and then when we
went into the war those increased a lot
and the Federal Reserve in one fashion
or another monetized that particular
debt the real question is whether we can
use that money productively or whether
it's wasted if it's if it's productive
and also most importantly if our society
is cohesive I think that we can get
through this in a managed way much like
a war however what really worries me is
the fragmentation the the anger or the
carelessness of one extreme or another
to messed up the continued improvement
of the pie
I think there's an opportunity here to
restructure the system to be in a better
way but it really requires I think a
cohesiveness a bipartisanship a respect
an understanding and empathy for the
various sides involved so that that's
done intelligently and the country has
brought together rather than fighting
because history has shown like in the
Great Depression if you don't go from
country to country the reactions were
very different in fact it in in Europe
and Japan for countries that were
democracies the internal fighting was so
bad that the parliaments their their
Congress's chose to have autocratic
system special rights in this is lurking
to power 1933 because the internal
fighting was so great and there's some
there could be a move toward more
autocratic and confrontational types of
policies and because this is a world
problem this is not just the u.s.
problem this is a world problem and
there's competitions going on in the
world you know there's a China's the
rising power and then there's
a lot of the part of the world that
won't have the support that the United
States has because we're blessed to have
the world central bank we can produce
dollars and dollars or a reserve
currency that means they can be spent
all around the world than they're
accepted very few currencies on are like
that no currencies like the US dollar so
in a lot of parts of the world they're
not going to be able to fill those holes
that the Federal Reserve can fill so
we're going to see a change I think in
the world order and it's going to be
they'll be anger and it could be
fighting so how that's handled I think
is the most important thing and that's
related to this question from YouTube
pear / asks are you see are you seeing
any geopolitical risks or limitations of
what the government can do I mean you're
touching on this I mean how do you think
that'll evolve and what advice you know
how do we navigate you mentioned there's
polarization in this country there might
be polarization globally what what can
people do proactively to get to the
better outcome well first I I'd like to
draw your attention to a series that I'm
writing on LinkedIn which is called the
changing world order and what it is is
it looks at history going back the last
five hundred years because the same
things happen over and over again for
almost the identical reasons and one
could see where we are now as I say very
similar in the 35 the 1930 and 45 period
or other cycles and so what happens is
when you have a great empire the world's
leading Empire and it becomes more
vulnerable as it becomes financially
overextended if the education isn't the
same and if various when rivals rise to
strengthen it on that's a time that it
becomes challenged by the in other words
it can be perceived as a time of
weakness and history has shown that it's
also a time of economic difficulty and
that leaders tend to be more populous
more nationalists more confrontational
and so that is why there's a tendency of
conflicts geopolitical conflicts world
conflicts that followed oppression
periods and so it's something that we
have to be aware of there are tensions
with Iran tensions with China tensions
there and if it's perceived as the time
of vulnerability it can produce conflict
history has shown that to be the case
over and over again so in the end that
piece we go back to 500 years and you
see the patterns and it's something to
be scared about now the second part of
that question is what do we do about it
the question is we you know we work for
common people
we each have whatever influence we have
the most important thing is the behavior
of the people who have their hands on
the lever of level levers of power and
so they will make those decisions
and so I guess we affect them and we we
have a right to some extent to choose
them and we also hopefully don't make it
so polarized that we're in this battle
to together and so countries dealing
with each other just like the
individuals or the political faction as
those of the left and those are the
right within the country hopefully
realized that the path of doing it
peacefully and productively is so much
better than the path of conflict because
if maybe that's the thing to pass around
because if there is conflict that
conflict creates its own problems its
own economic problems its own social
problems and and that creates the worst
economic output so which really comes
down to how we are with each other
ya know and speaking about that from
YouTube
Andres Pena Rhonda asks please walk us
through the restarting process of the
economy and maybe even how that might
relate to the geopolitics but especially
the economic would it be possible to
come back suddenly from a 20 percent
unemployment rate while after the 2008
recovery was quite more slow in what
you're suggesting is this might be a
deeper recession or even depression than
2008 yeah I think it's I think it's
important I understand
mm-hmm that there's a productive economy
and so if there were no financial pieces
no balance sheets and income statements
there's you know just imagine there was
no savings and no financial assets
there's that's kind of one part of the
economy and it works with the other part
of the economy which is the financial
part of the economy assets you know you
lend somebody money they have to pay you
back and so on and they're both
operating together so if we didn't have
the financial part of the economy and
didn't have to have a debt restructuring
you'd almost imagine okay you can go on
and where could the economy produce well
they could produce at whatever level
it's capable of and so it was not
impaired by the virus you know why not
go do the other things but when we have
money and we have credit we have
accounting and so we have come companies
with debts you know like I live in the
state of Connecticut in the state of
Illinois and so on they have their own
financials and so the financial
consequences of that means that certain
people are going to need payments and
when they go finacially broke then
that's going to have that's going to be
the impediment
so the impediment to growth is largely
the financial impediment to growth and
that is why I got so important to be
dealt with I don't you know we we could
all hear what we hear
the virus you know there is a wide range
of possibilities it's certainly the case
in investment pandemics that the
possibility of it coming and going and
not being easy to deal with economically
could persist for a while and become
those economic consequences are very
important so we're going to come out of
it with a restructuring when it one day
it'll be gone and we will have a
restructured economy then who will pay
what taxes who will have what wealth and
how the resources will be distributed I
think will be restructured and how
that's done will be important to make
sure that it's a productive way and that
restructuring is historical so as I say
nineteen thirty to forty five we started
29 to 32 38 really along we had a
depression and 33 they printed a lot of
money and then we went into a war and
then we had a giant restructuring and
1945 we began again and so and then we
were often had a period of prosperity
and that's that's normally the case
man's capacity to adapt and an invent is
tremendous that's the greatest force so
while we go through these restructurings
I think that at the same time there's
this tremendous capacity to adapt and
restructure and get on to doing it again
so I'm confident we'll get it behind us
but I think it's probably going to take
a few years and on that just to break
down some of what you said you know in
the financial world when you talk about
a restructuring this is a company has
some debt has to make interest payments
it might have to renew that debt after
some period and then if for example if
you're an airline and you're bringing in
no revenue there's no way to pay that
debt that's the type of restructuring
you're talking about and then separately
and then separately there's a reap you
guys you can see the real economy
irrespective of how peep
financed things and and that's where
you're saying that that might not sorry
I didn't mean since row no no go ahead
no no I'm just trying to paraphrase make
sure there's three drink it'll also be a
restructuring of who pays the bills
so yeah they'll be the corporate
restructuring and somebody will have an
opportunity to let's say by that airline
cheaply the debtors look then we may not
fly as much and so I don't know they'll
be less planes and it'll all be adapted
to in that system and then at the same
time excuse me and then at the same time
we're in a position where they're going
to have to be changes in taxes and
changes in restructuring wealth and and
those kinds of changes it means they may
affect how states are going to get it
they may expect how do we spend money on
education they may affect how we're
spending money on health care we're
going to have to spend we're going to
learn to save more because a lot of
entities realize that they didn't have a
cushion so there'll be more savings and
less spending and it'll be reconstructed
as to how we do you know taxes and
spending and all of that - and what I'm
hearing from you is you're definitely
not seeing kind of an immediate bounce
back if tomorrow the coronavirus just
disappeared it's not like that
everything would just get rosy overnight
there might be just you know the people
who've lost their jobs they might not be
hired immediately they have less
purchasing power so what I'm hearing
from you is it could be several years
for it to get back to normal this could
be this will go on a while because of
those economic consequences and also
consider that it's going to be worse in
countries that don't have reserve
currency central banks most of the world
and also we're going to make an
adjustment in sound for self-sufficiency
you know we were on a path to greater
self-sufficiency because of the rivalry
and could be conflict with China and
others in terms of we're a highly
globalized economy becoming much more of
a self sufficiency economy and even
individuals are becoming more
self-sufficient and that meant that the
efficiencies that we had by producing
wherever the it's most cost-effective to
produce it and ship it easily around the
world that paradigm is shifting so we're
going from an interconnected world to a
world that is going to be much more
independent and that will make for less
efficiencies and supply lines for
example and so that will have an effect
all of those are like sand in the gears
and what's your sense given that this
could be a protracted recession or
depression the likes of which we haven't
seen since the 1930s you're a student of
the market or what's your sense of the
last few weeks the market seems to be
getting more and more optimistic well I
think it's very much like March 1933 so
let me recount there was a bubble the
20s were the Roaring Twenties and people
borrowed money to bet on it continuing
that was very much like the time we were
on in people were borrowing money
companies were buying money to buy back
stocks and so on and then there was the
the bubble burst and so from 29 until
1930 to 30 and then the beginning of 33
1932 we had the dive Roosevelt was
elected he was more of a populist of the
left to redistribute and in March 19
March 5th 1933 he announced the program
that's very much the same as the program
that we announced Americans announced on
the presidency Congress and the Federal
Reserve on April 9 and that bottom that
represented the exact
in the stock market the exact bottom in
the economy because it produced a wave
of money that hit and so while we went
from it from the low in the economy in
in 1932 into the beginning of 33 there
was a pickup in the economic activity
that carried further along so the
depression reaching its economic
activity it took about ten years for the
economy to get back a little less than
ten years and it really took going into
the war to get back where it was so I
think it'll be somewhat similar that
what happens is there was the big
printing of money and we call that
reflation and with that reflation that
is what's supporting assets like this so
you see both stocks and gold go up
however we're in a period of time where
there's massive differences you know you
talk about the stock market as a whole
but the differences between the winners
and the losers is enormous and so when
looking at stocks or looking at any
asset we have to take appreciate the
differences that exist be there and also
there's not much leeway in interest
rates so you know the what best way to
get stocks to go up is to get interest
rates to go down so there's a floor so I
think we're in an environment in which
you're not going to see the return to
normalcy but you're seeing this weight
of money
forced create the bottom right around
the same time same way as April 9th was
March 5th 1933 you're seeing that weight
of money come in and have that effect
and then and well I don't think it's
going to take it to where anything where
it was goods conditions are much worse
balance sheets income statements and
then there's going to be the value of
money question you know gold and other
assets and store holds of wealth will
enter into the picture so I think it's
similarly and that differentiation is
going to be very important to know where
to invest in where not to invest so it's
not so much that you're doubting the
market that the market is as you said
there's this weight of money kept
flowing in and it has to go someplace
and that might be maybe forming
something of a bottom or do you think
that the market as a whole is being
overly optimistic given some of the more
pessimistic some scenarios that might
happen well we take the market as a
whole what we have is the federal
reserve in the federal government I
believe saying we will do whatever it
takes and so if you saw that amount of
money you know we've seen we're going to
see another two trillion I think you'll
see whatever amount of money it takes
and that means so we're on that kind of
a path the question will increasingly
also be what is the value of money and
whether it's a store hold of wealth and
so that becomes the nest next risk to
worry about so that's why I keep
referring to store holds of wealth and
stocks at the same time as there's that
reflation going on because if you go
down again and the unemployment rate
goes up again and so on
the money's limit the money and credit
is just going to keep coming hmm I could
we could talk for our I know we've I
just really looked at the time and I
realized I've gone 10 minutes over so
thanks for staying with I do want to get
a chance to talk to you a little bit
about some of the amazing work that you
and Barbara are doing on philanthropy
tell us a little bit about this program
that you all have just announced I guess
even before the crisis show we're doing
some pretty impressive things in
Connecticut but especially around device
access most recently well Barbara I
guess you're referring to the lower
burden Mac but yeah Barbara worked yeah
in the poor school districts for the
last ten years to helping them and we we
decided that we would go we'd give a
hundred million dollars for the state of
Connecticut if the state of Connecticut
would match it
you get disengaged in disconnected high
school students students who wouldn't
make it through high school or stop
working to get them through high school
and into jobs and so we put that in
place and then we just put in about
sixty thousand computers for those
students because those poor students
don't have computers and they can't do
online learning and so that's one of the
things that we've done we we've done a
number of other things Food Program
supports of in other ways but I think
that's what you're speaking of and and
that's why we're excited to partner with
you and Khan Academy to get them the
great education that they otherwise
would not have so and it was great I I
really want to shout out to Dell because
you know that uh there was a shortage
there's a shortage of computers and how
they were responsive and how they price
those computers at cost and and provided
those 60,000 and then we put in about
twenty five million dollars to do that
we were able to were able to get them
and provide them education but it just
highlights the differences in the
conditions between you know the
different populations and basic things
like education or computers so yeah
we're thrilled to do that you know
hopefully together with with what the
wonderful work you're doing know that
you know I'm talking to a lot of folks
these days and Khan Academy as much as
we hope it can help a lot of folks you
need that device access you need that
internet access so the work that y'all
are doing in Connecticut is incredible
and we're hoping it can set an example
for many other groups around the country
or the world so Rea thank you so much I
hope you can join this I mean we have so
many questions that I didn't get to I
probably got to 5% of the questions that
people are asking I personally would
also like to go much deeper on some of
these economic questions to make sure I
understand it a little bit better but
thank you so much for joining today and
I hope we can do this again sometime
soon it was a delight any time you want
look forward to it
thanks ray
so thanks everyone for joining today
this was a great conversation thanks for
all of your questions I I think we will
be able to convince ray to join again
and get to more of these questions but
once again thanks for joining this is a
really fun way for all of us to stay in
touch during these time this time of
social distancing I will remind you if
you are in a position to do so please
think about donating to Khan Academy and
we look forward to seeing you in future
live streams tomorrow we're going to
have 4-star General Stanley McChrystal
on and we're going to talk a lot of
questions about motivation and staying
focused and and a little bit about maybe
some of the the geopolitics of what we
might be going into so thanks for
joining thank you arrey and I will see
everyone tomorrow
you